when a dead man Rises how does he come
to bear with his unnatural existence for
every story deserves an ending and
without one
what is there to treasure so he looks
for purpose in his undeath a notoriously
difficult task but even a cursed undead
want to believe they're special
it seems first he joins a legion United
in their resolve a pack of wolves sworn
to do battle with the dark where ever it
arises the same dark they say that is
responsible for the curse of the undead
battling against Horrors and monsters
like heroes past battling themselves for
that is where the true corruption lies
until one day the man turns coat and
leaves unable to bear the burden for
even in undeath Hawk would feared his
mortality he clutched a shield close to
his chest unlike his brothers and
sisters before with a blade designed to
catch and deflect mortal strikes Hawk
would the Kraven the crest form
however by nature of definition it is
the coward who is capable of the highest
heroism for his obstacles are the
greatest of all are you the next mother
or merely a pullin of fate he believed
that he could still be a hero a champion
to banish the dark with the light of the
first flame someone worthy of a throne a
place in this world that is engraved
with his name Hawkwood an undead worthy
of fire but again he failed a nameless
saker's that undead unfit even to be
cinder and so he becomes ash
when a dead man rises he becomes his
failure forced to know that his best was
not nearly enough another one roused
from the sleep of death well you're not
alone we unkilled are worthless God
isn't die right
gives me conniptions and it have us seek
the Lords of cinder and return them to
their moulding thrones but we are
talking true legends with the metal to
link the fire we're not fit to lick
their boots don't you think
each of them a man who actually became a
filing King king not for 13 but for
might such as a lord I suppose but here
I ask do we have a sodding chance how
could a Chien failures possibly hope to
convince four Lords to listen to them
well if the Lord's will not return to
their thrones themselves let them return
as cinders you oft the Lords of cinder
the undead legion so that's how they're
delivered to their thrones I pity the
sorry Souls is that really Lordships
last reward
it finally hit him the absurdity of it
all the poor wretched souls be they Lord
or legend the curse shows no mercy what
a sham and if Kings could not escape
their fate well then they were no lesser
than he so what did he have to fear
nothing I'm a deserter I know but I've
still plenty of fight in me first he
followed the wolf then he was scarred by
fire finally he finds the courage to
pursue another calling the calling of
those who seek to exist outside of the
cycle but to be alive is to be
vulnerable and even the fiery gods no
exception to that rule
No the muscles of the Dragon seek
another plane of existence one which
transcends life and we possess one of
their relics
oh you've returned I was hoping to see
you
not crestfallen [ __ ] what he handed
me this he's changed a great deal since
he left this place grave enough place he
asked me to give a game it was a
challenge this time invites us something
else completely without a shield to
protect his own self ah there you are
well I've decided to stop running from
my fate loathe me all you like I shall
take what makes you Dragon
this should be no petty offense as the
true dragon I shall take what is
rightfully mine
I should have known
enough fool
[Music]
yes bloody mad is he like trapped within
your glass
[Music]
you are dragon more dragon vampire
desert could hoped for no better place
to buy
his name was Hawk would the last
remaining warrior of the undead legion
[Music]
this video is sponsored by me if you
enjoy my content if this prepare to cry
made you cry then you can now support
them and you get something comfy in
return so just scroll down and you'll
see shirts and hoodies below the video
you guys also know that I love working
with artists and this was a rare
opportunity to work with a legendary one
this is the hugely talented ceebot and
this guy is a real Ari Armas just take a
look at some of the art that he creates
our piece is this demonic version of my
YouTube character he comes in 4
different colors and he stands flaming
hands and it's got an eclipse in the
background and he's surrounded by a
field of familiar weaponry I think this
part is really cool see if you can put a
name to all of the weapons here so only
really avid fans will realize that this
shirt is related to Dark Souls and this
shirt is related to my channel so I
think it's abstract and stylish enough
for you to want to wear it in public and
that's kind of the line I wanted to walk
I've made sure that I sampled all of
these products before hand so I can
vouch for their material quality I would
just want to say be aware if you choose
a dark color for the background because
the weapons might not be completely
visible but light colors work really
well as always thank you for watching
hope you enjoy the merch and I'll see
you next time
there is something huge just around the
corner so look forward to that
[Music]